la crisis climática afecta con
particular fuerza a nuestro continente
americano
a nuestro continente americano y también
en particular al Caribe
y a los sistemas de vida de nuestra
gente en Chile de hecho cumplimos con
siete de los nueve criterios de
vulnerabilidad establecidos por las
Naciones Unidas por nosotros mismos
áreas de borde costero de baja altura
son las áridas y semiáridas zonas de
bosques propensión a los desastres
naturales sequía y desertificación zonas
urbanas con contaminación atmosférica y
ecosistemas montañosos
sin embargo nuestro país como
seguramente muchos de los de ustedes
muchos de los del sur global
produce y es responsable de una parte
mínima en nuestro caso el 0,24% de las
emisiones globales del efecto
invernadero
mientras los países de las economías más
grandes del g20 como nos recordaba el
secretario general
produce el 80% de los gases con efecto
invernadero
como resulta evidente en estos días
ningún país sea grande pequeño humilde o
poderoso puede pretender salvarse solo
mientras preparaba en mi país este
discurso pensaba como en medio de tantos
discursos de seguro muy interesantes
contando la realidad específica de cada
país podía aportar con un pequeño grano
de arena a la construcción de un mundo
más justo y posible
y consciente de que no soy quien
para dar lecciones sobre cada uno de los
problemas que vive el mundo convulso en
el que habitamos pensé que contarles
nuestra experiencia reciente como país
puede servir a quien quiera escuchar
para sacar
vuestros propios aprendizajes
chile vive actualmente un intenso
proceso político
hace casi tres años debimos hacer frente
a una grave crisis política y social
durante aquellos días una gran mayoría
de chilenas y chilenos manifestó su
malestar frente a la desigualdad y los
abusos
su indignación frente a las largas
esperas para recibir atención en la
salud pública
su activo frente a las millonarias
deudas por estudiar
su rechazo a las pensiones de miseria
después de largos años de trabajo
es quizás una historia conocida para
muchos de ustedes
Dentro de pocos meses
se cumplirán
50 años
desde que el presidente Salvador Allende
desde esta misma testera que tengo el
honor de estar hoy día
diera cuenta de los importantes cambios
sociales y políticos que vivían nuestro
país
porque somos un país que lleva largo
tiempo buscando su camino propio hacia
la dignidad
Y si bien Durante los gobiernos
democráticos de los últimos 30 años se
redujo notablemente la pobreza y hubo
importantes avances en materia social
resulta indeleble que el modelo de
desarrollo que adoptamos en Chile ha
mantenido una alta concentración de la
riqueza llevándonos a ser uno y esto nos
duele los duele colegas uno de los
países más desiguales del mundo
esta desigualdad como de seguro también
pasa en muchas de las Naciones en vías
de desarrollo
a obstaculizado
Nuestro camino al desarrollo pero no
solo eso es una amenaza latente para la
democracia
pues fractura la sociedad misma destruye
la cohesión social y por lo tanto
termina siendo un impedimento para
entendernos y construir juntos y juntas
un devenir que sea más libre y más justo
el estallido social que viviera chile en
2019 dejó perplejos a muchos
observadores algunos de ustedes que
preguntaban qué está pasando en este
país y también algunos actores de la
vida nacional
Y es que a muchos les llamó la atención
que un país que ha logrado índices
importantes de crecimiento económico y
de desarrollo humano que dan cuenta de
importantes mejoras de la calidad de
vida de su población se haya visto
enfrentado a la vez a una crisis tan
profunda
desgraciadamente
lo que ocurrió en mi patria no fue casal
no fue casualidad sino la consecuencia
de innumerables historias de dolor y
postergación que se fueron incubando y
afectando el corazón mismo de nuestra
sociedad
y quiero decirles que aquello
aunque no se espere puede pasar en sus
países también por eso los quiero
invitar a anticiparse anticiparnos todos
juntos en la búsqueda de una mayor
justicia social
distribuir de mejor manera la riqueza y
el poder débil de la mano con un
crecimiento sostenible y tengo la
profunda convicción que espero sea
compartida de que aquello es posible y
es urgente
desgraciadamente debo decirlo porque a
cada uno no puede solamente venir a
hablar de las cosas
buenas
este descontento se manifestó también
en graves episodios de violencia
como la inaceptable y quema de
estaciones de metro y la vandalización
de centros cívicos y por otro lado
fuimos testigos de una represión
descontrolada que terminó con muertes
heridos y más de 400 personas Víctimas
de trauma ocular producto de la acción
del Estado lo que constituye desde el
punto de vista de nuestro gobierno y de
organismos internacionales de Derechos
Humanos en una grave violación a los
Derechos Humanos que debe ser reparada y
así lo será
fue estimados colegas una larga historia
de injusticia es la que se expresó en
nuestro país en diciembre
y en octubre del 2019
pero también y esto es Lo lindo de cómo
las historias son más largas que
nosotros mismos quienes hoy día ocupamos
estos puestos también fue la historia
larga de la movilización ciudadana y las
luchas sociales
esa que permitió el retorno a la
democracia el reencuentro de los
demócratas Como dijera el presidente
Erwin A fines del siglo pasado o la que
los arbores del siglo 20 permitió
avanzar en derechos para los
trabajadores y trabajadoras
en las manifestaciones del 2019 también
estaban las mujeres del siglo pasado que
avanzaron pese a todo hacia el derecho a
voto femenino
nos acompañaron el recuerdo de los
obreros que lograron el derecho al
descanso y los pobladores que lucharon y
siguen luchando por una vivienda digna
son todas esas memorias y luchas
sociales las que estuvieron presentes
y los valores detrás de este profundo
malestar la igualdad la justicia la
libertad no son ajenos a un reclamo que
cada vez con más frecuencia vemos en el
mundo y en esta testera
la protección y promoción de los
Derechos Humanos en cualquier parte y
por cualquier régimen el trabajo decente
la protección social universal la lucha
contra la crisis climática son demandas
universales que son el foco de nuestra
agenda en común liderada por nuestro
secretario general Antonio Gutiérrez y
de los objetivos del desarrollo
sostenible
estimados líderes del mundo
la salida para caminar en la solución
pacífica y democrática de la crisis que
vive nuestro país fue un acuerdo
importante entre las principales fuerzas
políticas que permitió la elaboración de
una ruta hacia la redacción de una nueva
constitución
una que fuera capaz de sentar las bases
de un nuevo contrato social
esta ruta
impulsada por la sociedad chilena desde
la protesta y la lucha social y
encausada políticamente por diversas
instituciones fue refrendada por un
plebiscito de entrada en donde un 80 por
ciento un 80% de los votantes se
manifestó a favor de una nueva
constitución
escrita por un órgano especialmente
electo para aquello
y el desafío no es menor
consiste en lograr como nunca antes en
nuestra historia una constitución
democrática escrita con participación
ciudadana con participación de los
pueblos indígenas y con paridad entre
hombres y mujeres
una constitución para todos y todas pero
también hecha por todos y todas
hace algunas semanas sin embargo el
trabajo realizado por la convención
constitucional entre 2020 entre 2021 y
2022 fue sometido a consultas ciudadana
a través de un plebiscito en que los
chilenos y chilenas participaron de
nuevo masivamente un 85% de
participación Y en este evento electoral
los ciudadanos rechazaron de manera
clara la propuesta por un 62 contra un
38%. por lo que hoy como país Estamos
buscando nuevas fórmulas para construir
ese lugar de encuentro entre todos los
chilenos y chilenas
mi opción personal en ese plebiscito fue
de aprobar la propuesta que nos hacía la
convención pero el resultado fue en
contrario
algunos han querido Ver el resultado del
plebiscito como una derrota del gobierno
Y con toda humildad quiero hoy día
decirles a estas Naciones Unidas que
nunca Un gobierno puede sentirse
Derrotado cuando el pueblo se pronuncia
en democracia la palabra popular es
soberana y la guía para todo momento
pero por qué les hablo de esto porque a
diferencia del pasado en que las
diferencias en Chile fueron resueltas a
sangre y fuego hoy las chilenas y los
chilenos acordamos enfrentar de manera
democrática nuestros desafíos
y se los cuento porque estoy seguro que
uno de los principales desafíos de la
humanidad hoy día es el de construir
democracias que de verdad le hablen y le
escuchan a la gente y que acepten los
resultados cuando no son los esperados
quienes asistimos a esta asamblea
tenemos el deber de mejorar
nuestras democracias
durante las multitudinarias jornadas de
movilización la palabra dignidad se hizo
presente
Pues bien este mismo pueblo
se acaba de expresar dándonos una
lección de democracia que tomamos
chile le ha exigido a su democracia y a
sus actores políticos estar a la altura
de sus demandas y el desafío de hoy que
tenemos nosotros estar también a la
altura de ellas
como gobierno
hemos recogido los resultados del
reciente plebiscito con los ojos y el
corazón bien abiertos
Queremos escuchar lo que el pueblo nos
está diciendo porque confiamos en su
criterio y confiamos en su voluntad y
hay cosas que hemos entendido muy
claramente y que quiero brevemente
compartir con ustedes
los resultados son la expresión de una
ciudadanía que demanda cambios Sin poner
en riesgo sus logros presentes que
quiero un mejor futuro construido con
seriedad y sin caer en nuevas
inseguridades
un futuro de cambio con estabilidad
y hemos entendido también y esto como
joven que hace pocos años estaba en la
calle las protestas
que representar el malestar es mucho más
sencillo que producir las soluciones
para esto
que quienes nos dedicamos al exigente
tarea de la política muchas veces
confundimos con facilidad los éxitos que
podemos tener como voceros de la molesta
ciudadana con nuestra real capacidad de
ser constructores de mejores futuros
y el resultado del plebiscito en nuestro
país nos ha enseñado a ser más Humildes
la democracia debe ser humilde y asumir
que la construcción del chile que
soñamos no está en las recetas de ningún
sector en particular sino en la síntesis
que podamos hacer combinando lo mejor
que cada uno puede aportar
así se gobierna El Siglo 21
movilizando Las capacidades y la
sabiduría de nuestras sociedades y no
pretendiendo sustituirlas
como presidente de Chile estoy
convencido de que en el corto plazo
chile tendrá una constitución que nos
satisfaga y nos enorgullezca una ha
construida en democracia que recoja el
aporte de todos los sectores de la
sociedad y que sea capaz de reflejar los
anhelos de justicia y Libertad
estimadas y estimados delegados desde la
humilde historia de mi patria puedo
decirles con mucha convicción que el
camino para enfrentar los problemas que
aquejan a nuestras sociedades
se pavimenta con más democracia y no con
menos
incentivando la participación y no
restringiéndola fomentando el diálogo y
jamás censurándolo y por sobre todo
respetando a quien piensa distinto
incorporando sus puntos de vista y
entendiendo que el tener opiniones
diversas no nos vuelve enemigos me
revelo frente al Abismo que algunos
pretenden cavar ante la legítima
diversidad de opiniones y desde chile
declaramos nuestra voluntad de ser
constructores de puentes ante estas
brechas que nos impiden encontrarnos
como sociedades diversas
Esta es la experiencia y el aprendizaje
que desde nuestro pequeño país queremos
compartir con las naciones del mundo
profundizar la democracia es un
ejercicio permanente en el cual solo
cabe perseverar y aprender cada uno de
las experiencias del otro por eso y ya
terminando Los invito a trabajar en
conjunto para fortalecer la democracia
en todos los espacios en cada país y en
la relación entre nosotros
necesitamos una voz unida de América
Latina necesitamos más trabajo conjunto
desde el sur global necesitamos unas
Naciones Unidas modernizadas en donde
todos nos pongamos mismos objetivos
a comprometernos desde el
multilateralismo con la justicia y la
paz en todo momento Y en todo lugar a
realizar las acciones que sean
necesarias y no solo declaraciones para
detener la injusta guerra de Rusia
contra Ucrania y poner fin a todos los
abusos de los poderosos en cualquier
lugar del mundo
a movilizar nuestros esfuerzos para
detener la violencia contra las mujeres
sea en Irán en memoria de masa a mini
Muerte en manos de la policía esta
semana o en cualquier lugar del globo
a no naturalizar las permanentes
violaciones a los Derechos Humanos
contra el pueblo palestino haciendo
valer el derecho internacional y la
resoluciones que año tras años también
más asamblea establece que conduzcan a
su derecho inalienable a establecer su
propio estado libre y soberano como
también a garantizar el legítimo derecho
de Israel a vivir dentro de fronteras
seguras e internacionalmente reconocidas
a seguir trabajando para contribuir a la
liberación de los presos políticos en
Nicaragua y trabajar para que En ningún
lugar del mundo tener distintas ideas
del gobierno de turno pueda terminar en
persecución o en vulneración de los
Derechos Humanos
estimados miembros de esta asamblea el
mundo entero demanda cambios y que no
somos parte de las nuevas generaciones
aprendiendo de quienes nos antecedieron
tenemos el derecho y la responsabilidad
de pensar y actuar para un futuro
distinto los ciudadanos que más sufren
las consecuencias de sociedades
construidas desde la segregación y la y
el abuso reclaman derechos reclaman
seguridad para vivir ese mundo de mayor
bienestar solo lo podríamos lograr
lograr con mayor democracia y ese es el
llamado al que todos y todas debemos hoy
día atender y desde chile estamos
disponibles para colaborar en cada lugar
del mundo en aquello Muchísimas gracias